en quoi puis-je vous aider
rien ne me satisfait
je suis souvent en colère
c'est pour ce genre de truc que les gens
vous demandent de l'aide non
[Musique]
toute ma vie j'ai réfléchi et encore
réfléchi j'ai essayé de comprendre qui
j'étais pour être en mesure d'aider mes
patients à se comprendre même pour
qu'ils aient une meilleure relation aux
autres
tu devrais peut-être refaire une
thérapie
c'est vous que je veux je veux un expert
je ne suis pas normal j'ai besoin de me
faire aider d'après mon expérience quand
quelqu'un fait tout ce chemin il fait le
choix d'entamer une thérapie il n'hésite
pas à aborder les points difficiles
c'est qu'il peut être aidé j'ai des
problèmes plus graves que vous autres
patients
j'ai un besoin viscéral
de tuer des gens
donc vous voulez en savoir plus sur ma
vie
une thérapie soit efficace environnement
doit être sécurisant la peur est un
élément qui ne pourra que perturber le
bon déroulement de l'option
[Musique]
ça vous ennuie qu'on mange pendant la
séance